there's a new and unique dining
experience inside the planet 13
entertainment complex here in vegas
let's head to tressay eatery and spirits
[Music]
we're at tracy eatery and spirits
located at the plant 13
entertainment complex right up the strip
trey say is a really a mexican-american
restaurant
we specialize in you know a vast amount
of food dishes
we have everything from you know tacos
and enchiladas to
really like lamb chops and raviolis and
even
even some southern dishes and i think
really where we where we finish off is
our really specialty cocktails um
they're fabulous here and uh
we've become uh a favorite amongst
locals and tourists
we want to make you feel like you're in
a green house basically you look up you
see the blue skies
you look out to the side looks like
you're you're viewing the las vegas
strip
and we really wanted to create you know
a really high-end restaurant
that you could see and feel comfortable
enjoying you know whether it's you know
in the morning for breakfast or
at night for dinner we really try to
create environment in our bar area where
you can get really high specialty
cocktails really quality food
and be able to watch the game and
actually spend hours here manny you are
the chef
here after talking to david i've got the
munchies all right i'm ready to eat so
let's talk about these dishes
sure definitely so we have a little bit
for everybody um so right here we have a
little southern chicken and waffles uh
our homemade ravioli uh-huh
definitely go right ahead go right ahead
uh so we have a ricotta cheese ravioli
with the white wine sauce a little bit
of fresh seasonal vegetables
um you know it's something light you
know not too heavy
maybe lunch brunch you know if you're
feeling that mood
so we also go down to our shrimp and
grits our homemade uh
lobster cognac sauce creamy grits
blackened shrimp
you know and a little bit of cilantro on
top just has a garnish a little vibrant
colors so our fajitas you know obviously
grilled and cooked to order
slice it very thin that way you can
enjoy you know you could build your own
taco if you will
now i heard this is a show our server
does a little bit of tequila around it
hits it with the fire and it's just a
little show just a little wow factor for
the guests to enjoy
do it big in vegas now we have some
beautiful cocktails here
yes and you guys do specialize in that
here as well oh definitely so we have a
great variety of cocktails you know we
have happy hour you know a regular menu
you know our general manager category
she's a great mixologist as well
which which cocktail pairs well with the
ravioli because i want to taste
well you could really go with anything
you know what i mean obviously the the
fajita of mexico margarita can't go
wrong
no nice colorful like you set out
flavorful as well you know we uh
dehydrate our own our own fruits for the
cocktails
so i should just do any mini mining well
yeah go right ahead go right there all
right i'm going for this let's look at
the cactus
the cactus glass go ahead
is that like hibiscus what is that no
it's this one's actually
a prickly pear puree
and the salt around okay it's great i am
i am sold i am convinced i'm going to be
here
for breakfast lunch and dinner tressay
eatery and spirits inside the planet 13
entertainment complex
visit tristaylasvegas.com for more
information and join them for happy hour
from 3 p.m to 6 p.m monday through
friday